[Música]
y con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar sobre el control de armas
en eeuu un debate que divide a la
sociedad estadounidense según la
organización small arms survey en la
unión americana hay 120 armas de fuego
por cada 100 personas 2 tiroteos masivos
en eeuu en 15 días ponen nuevamente
sobre la mesa este tema a pesar de que
hay una gran cantidad de voces a favor
de una nueva regulación el uso de las
armas estaba contemplado por la segunda
enmienda de la constitución lo que ha
sumado a la amplia financiación de la
asociación nacional del rifle a la
política impuesta y también y esto
imposibilita los cambios precisamente
tres días después de la masacre de balde
en texas en la que murieron 19 niños y
dos profesoras la asociación anunció que
mantendrá su convención anual que se
realizará hoy viernes en houston a sólo
4 horas igual de donde ocurrió este
tiroteo propiciado por un joven de 18
años para ello entonces quiero saludar
en este momento a nuestro primer
invitado del día el s manuel oliver
padre de joaquín oliver su hijo fue
asesinado en la masacre parlan en el
estado de la florida y causando
de rif de verdad manuel un gusto tenerlo
en nuestro programa directo américa de
france 24 muy buen día
buenos días y gracias por la invitación
manuel en estados unidos hay más
tiroteos que días del año y es además el
país con más episodios en el mundo con
estos tiroteos no porque allí hay más
armas que en otras naciones aún hoy
después de tantas tragedias como valdés
como parlament donde falleció su hijo
pero justamente los se referían ustedes
mismos al alcance que tenemos con unos
políticos que tienen una alianza
demostrable con la industria de las
armas muchísimo el dinero que se mueve
en este país a través de esa industria
una industria que no tienen ningún tipo
de regulación en la nación de las
regulaciones y todo absolutamente todo
está regulado sin embargo los
fabricantes de armas tienen una luz
verde para hacer lo que les venga en
gana
un poco aliado a estos líderes políticos
que pasan a ser en algún momento unos
asesinos unos terroristas y están detrás
esos nombres que él mencionaba que están
detrás de cada uno de estos tiroteos
manuel por otro lado también la reacción
de las autoridades para intentar
proteger a los niños de los jóvenes en
el colegio ha sido oponer digamos algún
tipo de fuerza policial en todas las
sedes estudiantiles hacer requisas
realizar simulacros en caso de ataques
pero cómo afecta a estas medidas digamos
la salud mental de todos los estudiantes
nos intenta amenazados en su propio
recinto estudiantil
puede afectar muchísimo y es y es
inconcebible que un país del primer
mundo una potencia mundial tenga que
recurrir a esa medida que ignoré por
completo por conveniencia de nuestros
propios líderes el hecho de que las
armas están ocasionando este punto
tóxico en la sociedad es obvio en un
país donde ven más armas que personas lo
cual no quiere decir que cada persona
está armada lo que quiere decir es que
algunas personas tienen más de 100 armas
en su casa
eso no lo contemplan ellos es intocable
el tema del arma por eso nosotros
tenemos que decir las cosas claras estos
señores deberían ser penalizados por la
toda la comunidad del extranjero la
comunidad internacional así como lo
hacemos con criminales criminales de
guerra en otros países estos señores
deberían tener sanciones de parte de
otras personas porque en este país
simplemente están
por la libre nadie los confronta y nadie
se atreve a decir la verdad pero por qué
pasa precisamente esto con tantos con
tantas masacres tantos tiroteos sobre
todo en centros estudiantiles además que
dice sobre también lo que lo que apoyan
estas estas personas que están con la
asociación nacional del rifle en eeuu
qué problema no son las armas sino si no
las personas
bueno eso es un argumento extremadamente
extremadamente básico y tonto
por supuesto que las armas no se
disparan solos por eso que las
regulaciones se le se le imponen a las
personas y no a las armas por eso es que
un background es un chequeo de los
antecedentes que le hace a la persona
entonces yo creo que esa esos argumentos
tan elementales ya no pueden formar
parte de una discusión porque respeta el
momento
y baja de nivel cualquier progreso que
tengamos la intención de lograr de
cualquiera de los lados yo lo hablo con
toda sinceridad yo perdí a mi hijo en el
tiroteo de partner y hermoso y adorado
hijo joaquín es víctima de murió murió
con cuatro disparos de un ar-15
entonces explícame tú como eso no
significa una razón inmediata para tomar
una decisión distinta porque nueva
zelanda no sé no sé
e hizo lo mismo que aquí porque hay un
sentido común no existe un negocio de
las armas tan ha habido y tan agresivo
como el que hay aquí y hay la intención
de que los civiles estén resguardados
que ha cambiado es entonces manuel desde
que falleció su hijo en el 2018
no ha cambiado nada ha cambiado el hecho
de que ahora los los jóvenes los niños
tienen que estar entrenados para
sobrevivir estos tiroteos estamos a
punto a muy poco si es que ya no lo
estamos haciendo de que sea culpa de los
niños el hecho de que son tiroteados por
no seguir las instrucciones que les
fueron enseñadas esta es una ciudad que
planifica las escuelas en función de que
puede haber un tiroteo eso es lo que se
nos ha ocurrido como mejor solución sin
embargo vendemos en grandes cantidades
de dinero en otras naciones que están
sufriendo porque es razón que están
sufriendo por por por genocidios y
cuando tenemos nuestro propio genocidio
aquí esto sucede y todo el mundo se hace
la vista gorda yo no sabe cuántas
personas mueren al año aquí
45 mil el hecho de los tiroteos en las
escuelas representa un 2% 2% de lo que
significa el dibujo o amplio de la
violencia del azar el 60% son personajes
que se suicidan personas que tienen
acceso a un arma y terminan con su vida
compraron el arma bajo la mentira que
elena ley y que la sociedad le impuso de
que con un arma puede disfrutar de la
libertad y estar seguro y proteger a tu
familia por último manuel que cree que
está pasando en la sociedad
estadounidense en la juventud sobre todo
en la juventud estadounidense no no no
no es diferente a la juventud de otros
países la juventud estadounidense pues
practica deporte y juega videojuegos y
ve películas de agresión y ve películas
que no son agresivas igual que en japón
igual que en bogotá igual que en
venezuela igual que en buenos aries
igual que en madrid la diferencia es que
aquí hay una tienda de armas a la vuelta
de la esquina donde puedes ir a comprar
un ar-15 o quizás dos como fue el caso
de texas y 300 municiones
si eso no despierta una sospecha en una
sociedad explícame tú qué es lo que
estamos haciendo bien aquí hay que
determinar el daño determinar el cáncer
en dónde está y el cáncer bien
ocasionado por una industria que se
enriquece a dos días de la sangre de
nuestros niños